you
very few monsters in film and other
media are quite as prevalent as zombies
and with good reason
with so many more plausible disasters
looming around the corner such as war
climate change and financial ruin
zombies offer a gritty escape into a
future that while it may be scary we
know to be fiction on the one hand some
small part of us is terrified that a
zombie apocalypse could be possible but
on the other hand many of us hope for it
decades of zombie movies and video games
have given Preppers and would be zombie
hunters the information to prepare for
the inevitable rising of the dead but
how likely is it that we could actually
make it out alive what would it take to
survive a zombie apocalypse the first
things that probably come to mind are
guns baseball bats and giant ridiculous
trucks with push bumpers and while these
things are definitely valuable tools if
you have to use them you're probably in
the worst case scenario or you're just
reckless and either way you probably
won't last long what every survivor
really needs to focus on is the less
glamorous aspects of post-apocalyptic
life have seasonal allergies make sure
you have zyrtec on hand or risk getting
chomped by zombies who heard you
sneezing allergic to bees stock up on
epi pens unless you want to be that one
loser who died from a bee sting instead
of a hoard of living dead there are a
lot of little details to take into
consideration when trying to survive any
apocalypse the first and most obvious
necessities would be clean drinking
water food and general first-aid as a
rule of thumb each member of your party
should drink about one gallon of water
per day due to the physical exertion
required to exist in a world of ravenous
zombies that can add up quickly so make
sure you have a way to collect fresh
water either through purifying existing
water sources or desalinating ocean
water the average human can only go
about three days to a week without water
so regardless of your survival skills
having drinking water in abundance is
non-negotiable food is still critical
but more manageable while a lack of food
can lead to decreased physical fortitude
the average human can survive up to
three weeks without food as long as they
have plenty of water finally first aid
supplies like bandages hydrogen peroxide
and any needed prescription drugs will
be a lifesaver when someone in your
party inevitably hurts themselves a gash
from a rusty nail can be
as deadly as a zombie bite if not
treated quickly then there are the ever
useful utility items we all use in
everyday life duct tape alone has more
uses than you'd ever expect from
securing barricades to restraining
hostile humans to attaching knives to
poles for extra zombie killing reach
pocket knives or multi-tools will find
innumerable uses as well such as
sharpening steaks severing restraints or
opening cans of food then there are
flashlights many of us have gotten so
used to having a flashlight app on our
phones that we forget to keep a real
more powerful flashlight handy when your
phone eventually dies and there's no
power available having a flashlight
could be the difference between life and
death when traveling at night as for
transportation while a car or truck
might offer decent protection from the
zombies outside the engine noise will
also attract their attention and
potentially lead them to your hiding
spot opt for something quieter and more
maneuverable like a bike or if you're
intent on using a car steal somebody's
Tesla just be prepared for when power
sources stop working so you've got your
supplies and you're on the move looking
for somewhere safe to set up a base of
operations step 1 locate them all then
don't go there places where large
amounts of people can congregate are the
perfect breeding ground for zombies and
closed areas with large crowds make for
easy infection and with all the people
instinctively rushing to malls and
grocery stores to stock up on supplies
they're the last place you want to be
instead head for more isolated areas
your first option and potentially the
safest place near the average person
would be a tall highway overpass or
bridge if you could cart enough supplies
onto the bridge building materials food
maybe even farming implements soil and
seeds your party could destroy both ends
of the bridge and effectively separate
yourselves from the dangers below the
biggest risk here would be running out
of supplies as it would be very
difficult to go out and scavenge and get
back up another option would be a large
boat or yacht crewed by people you trust
most zombie lore suggests that the
Living Dead would be unable to swim due
to their ruined motor functions as long
as you were in deep enough water you'd
be completely isolated from zombies and
most of humanity as well the biggest
problem with using a modern boat is
their need for fuel if you run out of
gas you're dead in the water
so if you decide to set up an aquatic
base of operations
make sure you have as much fuel as you
can possibly carry to other hiding
places that could become an option
thanks to your boat would be small
uninhabited islands and offshore oil
rigs a private island would be ideal for
those with enough survival experience to
build shelter rain capture devices and
traps to catch wild animals and any
hostile humans who show up looking for a
fight your party would have plenty of
space to spread out depending on the
size of the island and the odds of
zombies showing up on your beach are
virtually zero if you can find an
uninhabited island far enough from other
land and people you can survive the end
of the world in relative comfort finally
a deep-sea oil rig is an ideal spot to
wait out the zombie apocalypse you'd be
miles from the nearest land suspended
well above the water level have plenty
of existing near indestructible metal
shelter and provided you have fishing
equipment you've got an endless supply
of food at your fingertips for those of
us who don't fancy the idea of building
shelter from scratch on a remote island
and value the security of a floating
fortress a deep-sea oil rig is the way
to go of course by choosing any of these
isolated hiding spots you limit your
ability to gather news and information
from the mainland which means you'll
need to make sure you have a radio or
some other form of communication with
the outside world to know when it's safe
to come home if ever could the human
race recover from a zombie outbreak
possibly with the military and the
Center for Disease Control working
together it's hard to imagine a scenario
where mindless monsters eradicate the
entire human race but it doesn't hurt to
be prepared and make sure you don't
become part of the Horde if you enjoyed
this video make sure to subscribe to
keep up to date with the latest content
and press that little bell under my
channel name to be notified every time I
release a new video you can watch my
previous video by clicking here or if
you're really bored you can watch all my
videos by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video